- Are you in the first
years of your career
and often sitting in meetings,
but you're often not really sure
how can I contribute?
How can I join the conversation?
How can I really add value?
This is a feeling that many
young professionals have.
And in this video, I'm going to share
a couple of tips and tricks
based on my experience
having worked in consulting at
McKinsey for about six years
on what you can do to succeed in meetings
as a junior consultant or as a junior guy
in corporate or in any
other roles similar to that.
So welcome to another coffee break here
on my channel, Firm Learning.
My name is Heinrich.
And on my channel I want to
help you to become successful
in the first years of your career.
So we now share three super tangible
and actionable tips and tricks
of what you can do to succeed
in such a meeting as a junior.
And for every tip I will share a little
very personal story based
on what happened to me
in my professional life to
really illustrate these points.
And then based on these little stories
I will always extract the learning
which I trust will help you
because for sure these were learnings
which were really valuable
and insightful to me.
But before we jump into it
I want to introduce you to
the sponsor of today's video.
And this sponsor is Skillshare.
Skillshare is an online learning community
with thousands of classes for
creative and curious people.
You can explore new skills,
deepen your passions and
get lost in creativity.
There are classes on marketing,
personal branding, presentation
skills and many more.
All of these are topics
that are highly applicable
to a career in consulting
banking or corporate.
And the best thing is that I
made a slight writing class
for Skillshare.
So you can access and enjoy
it as a Skillshare member.
Personally, I recently
took the class productivity
master class, principles and tools
to boost your productivity
from the fellow YouTuber, Ali Abdael.
It's a great class.
It taught me many new
aspects of productivity
and I very much enjoyed how he applied
the Pareto principle or the
80/20 rule to productivity.
Classes on Skillshare are
specifically curated for learning.
There are no ads.
They're always launching
new premium classes
so you can stay focused
and follow wherever
your creativity takes you.
And the best thing is that
it's less than $10 a month
with an annual subscription.
Skillshare created a special offer
for subscribers of this
channel Firm Learning.
And so the first thousand
subscribers of me
that click on this Skillshare
link in the video description
will get a free trial of the
Skillshare premium membership.
I hope this helps you to
explore your creativity.
Check it out. Link in
the video description.
So let's start with the first tip.
And indeed, let me share a story.
This is from an instance
that really happened
during my consulting professional life.
I was on a project and
we were having a workshop
with a client.
I was the responsible associate
who was supposed to cover this workshop.
So I sat together with a
client who was organizing it
from the client's side.
I discussed it with him a little bit.
I helped him draft some of the
materials for the workshop.
But then it looked all good.
The workshop was prepared
and then was happening.
On the workshop day the client
was leading the workshop
and I was pretty much just sitting there.
I was still a young associate.
He was presenting everything
and I tried it to make a
couple of remarks and comments
which I felt like were probably smart
and we're adding value.
But the truth also is
that in this long workshop
I didn't really add much
to the conversation.
And this is then indeed
also point of feedback
that I got from the project
lead after the workshop.
And she was telling me,
"Well, Heinrich, you
were a bit too passive.
"You were not active
enough as an associate.
"It should have been your role
"to shape the whole workshop a bit more."
So what I realized from
this episode is that
what I didn't do, what I should have done
is to clarify my role before the meeting.
And this is indeed the first tip
that I want to share with you.
Make sure that you clarify your role.
And this is true, both
for external meetings
but also for internal meetings.
Often our setting was in
these internal meetings.
There are some partners,
some senior partners, the project lead,
and then you're sitting
there as a young associate,
as a young consultant.
And then often you're lost.
I mean, what are you supposed to add
to the conversation, right?
And indeed then especially
when also clients are present,
then it's often the task
of the project lead,
or maybe even the partner
to moderate the discussion.
And often in these situations
you are as the junior guy,
also not the deepest subject matter expert
at the topic that is being discussed.
So on the content level,
you will also often struggle
to really participate and to add value,
especially in these situations
where all of these other
senior guys are present.
So my advice is that before
these meetings are taking place,
talk to the responsible person.
So this might be your client counterpart,
or maybe a project lead.
If now you're walking
into an internal meeting
with all your partners, really ask them,
how can you add value?
What should your role be?
And maybe make some suggestions.
What do you believe you could do.
And just some examples.
So what could you do?
So for instance, if you
present a larger document
maybe you would agree on a
certain section in the document
that you will present, that you will lead.
Maybe there will be a
certain flip chart session
during the workshop
and then you can lead this little session,
collect all the questions,
steer the whole discussion.
Maybe you will be the one
who writes all the notes
and then in the end writes
the meeting minutes.
So all of these are little things
that can increase your participation.
Your activeness will also
increase your visibility.
And if you are a regular
watcher of my channel,
you know how important in my opinion
visibility is for your career success.
And I specially made one video
about this topic of visibility.
I will link it somewhere above here.
It is also one of my older videos
but I believe the message in there
are still very, very valid.
Now for tip number two, let
me share an additional story.
And this is something that happened to me
when I was a project lead
and probably a similar
thing's also happened to me
with vigorous roles when
I was a more junior guy
on the team.
But at that instance,
I was a project lead.
I was sitting in a meeting
with one of my associates
and he also was a more junior associate.
He was only with the firm
for a couple of months.
And we were sitting at a meeting
which was part of his module, right?
So pretty much the meeting was in the end
his responsibility in the sense that
he was responsible to cover
the topics that were discussed.
So then during the meeting,
I as a project lead
tried to moderate the whole discussion
to steer the conversation
in the right direction.
But then there were occasional moments
where people were asking us about data,
about files that the sent us,
what certain numbers were,
how this all added up.
And my associate was just
sitting there pretty quiet,
pretty shy.
Didn't really say anything.
So then I ended up opening my laptop,
pulling out some files
and pretty much sharing
some pieces of information
that I wanted to share
back with the client.
And of course, to some extent here
my expectation would have been,
this is something that
the associate would do.
That as the module owner,
he would have all these files at hand
and would be able to share all
these numbers in the meeting.
And this now leads me to tip number two.
And this is that,
especially as the junior guy in the room.
Be the numbers guy.
So especially if this is a meeting
that is about one of the
topics that you are covering.
In these instances it actually
would even be expected
that of course, you know
all your data much better
and much more in detail
than the project lead.
Also needs to manage
other parts of the project
parallel to this specific part.
Of course you will have
all your files at hand.
Of course you will know
the most important numbers
concerning this work
probably even in your head.
You will not even need
a file for that, right?
So of course if questions
are asked about these topics,
this is your moment.
This is your role where you can jump in
and then share all this
information that you have at hand.
So being the numbers guy,
it's a straightforward
and actually pretty easy
little thing that you can do
as the junior guy to add some value
by providing the relevant data.
And I'd say, even if it's a question
which is not directly belonging
to your area of responsibility,
don't let your project
lead or your partner,
on a corporate context,
your boss or whatever,
look this stuff up.
If you have it, then
take this as your role.
You are the one who can
quickly look this up.
Ideally already come into the meeting
with maybe your laptop opened
with the most important
files or spreadsheets
which will likely to be the focus
of the discussion already opened.
So that if such a question comes up,
you do not need to
first look for this file
where you have saved
it, open it and so on,
but you directly have it in front of you.
You can directly tell them the numbers.
These are these little great
moments where you can shine.
Where you can add value.
And these are things
that will be perceived
by your team and also by the clients.
So tip number three.
And now again, a little story
from the perception of a project lead.
So often, which join meetings
that your associates scheduled
that are with clients that
are covered by your associates
just because of the
topic is a bit sensitive
or maybe the client has
quite a personality.
That maybe the associate
asked you to also jump in,
to sit in there to try to
help him to steer the meeting
into the right direction.
So, one thing that I
observed occasionally was,
(mumbles) I was sitting in these meetings,
I was trying to help and I
thought it was a great meeting.
And then the meeting was
over, all the clients left
and I was sitting there with the associate
and then I asked him or her,
"Hey, what do you think?
"How did the meeting go?"
And then the associate says,
"Well, yes. It went well.
"But we didn't ask the question.
"We didn't got this piece of information
"that we really needed."
And then this often confuse me.
And then I asked the person,
"Well, okay.
"But if you know that this was important,
"if you know that we needed
to ask this question as well,
"then why didn't you ask?"
And this was something that
I occasionally observed
with more junior consultants
that as soon as somebody
more senior than them
sits in the meeting, sits in the room.
Sometimes they feel like, okay,
now the meeting isn't my
responsibility anymore.
Or maybe they are too shy
and believe that well, if
this would be really important
then probably my project
lead or my partner
would think of that.
But of course often it's
the other way round, right?
Often the partner is the furthest away
from what is actually
going on in the project.
And the project lead will as well
be already much further away
than you as an associate.
So take this as your
responsibility as well.
And this is my third tip.
So make sure that all the key results,
that all the next steps are
really clear and defined.
And if you feel like for whatever reason
that something important
is just not raised
by the more senior people in the room,
but you know that it is important,
then raise it.
Then ask the question.
Then address it.
Do not believe that that is
not your role to ask this
or that you're too intimidated
to address this point
that you know is so important.
Of course be aware of politics.
Maybe it's a very sensitive thing.
Maybe there was a reason
that the project lead
or whoever was sitting in there
with you, didn't raise it.
So of course try to be sensitive
for these types of things as well.
But in general, I believe
that it really rarely hurts
if you as the junior guy really
pushed for tangible results
and next steps that I
agreed in the meeting.
So I hope that you find
these three tips helpful.
So first clarify your role.
Second, be the number guy.
And third, push for clear
next steps and results.
If you do this
I trust you will add lots
of value to the meeting.
And this would give you a very clear sense
of what you actually can do
if you sit in these conversations.
So as always, if you have any
questions about all of this
please leave me a comment
below in the comment section.
As you know, I will answer
every single comment
that you write.
And of course, every
comment that you write
also helps with the YouTube systems.
If you took any value
out of this video at all,
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm
and also subscribe to my channel
to stay up to date on all my content.
If you want to see even more from me,
also follow me on my Instagram.
My handle is Firm Learning.
You can also reach out to me on LinkedIn
or sign up for my mailing list.
Both of these links you can find below
in the video description.
If you want to start learning
and claim that free trial
use the link below in the
video description to sign up.
And I wanna end by also saying thank you
to all the members of Firm Learning.
You're really making a
significant contribution
to my work on this channel.
So if you're thinking about
becoming a member as well
and also profit from member only parts,
hit the join button next
to the subscribe button
to learn what this is all about.
If you've watched until here,
thank you for watching until the end.
I'm releasing new videos
every single Saturday.
So looking forward to
next week, next Saturday
to the next video.
Until then, goodbye.
This is Heinrich from Firm Learning.
Cheers guys.